hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich stehe heute hier nicht
alleine steht zusammen mit dem waffel
sehr gut und kelly und wie ihr seht habe
ich hier drei pfeile nicht irgendwelche
richtig schmidt wirklich wie kelly sagen
würde richtig spitze
aber ich würde sagen extrem talentierten
fünf würfe fünfter und gewinnt derjenige
der die meisten auf lucky aber bleibt
bis zum ende dran weil es gibt eine
unangenehm zu straße mehrheit der letten
muss ihn stellen wie man wie beim
bolzplatz und dann müssen alle
jetzt kommen wieder zugeschlagen
zwei würfe und diesmal nicht machen
anstanden wertung man prüfen genau
[Applaus]
willst du mit
wurde ich hätte mir mehr erwünscht junge
junge junge junge weil wir erst mal neue
luftballons frankleben sie werden ins
durch zuweisungen nicht aufgestockt
deutlich wird sturm steht am start und
wird als nächster seine fünf würfe
abgeben
sehr gespannt kelly hat auf jeden fall
schon vorgelegt ob ich das noch aufholen
kann
vielleicht passiert mir ist einfach
alles wow ich wünsche dir ganz ganz
wenig glück und dass du die strafe gut
ich werde echt gar nichts ich kann das
überhaupt nicht also einer der fußball
dann bin ich verbessere märkte wie den
schon bei einer noch dann bin ich auf
jeden fall schon nicht lässt was willst
du absolut ist okay aber nicht letzter
zeit mit raffungen bin ich auf jeden
fall nicht dabei auch wieder finale
runde
mindestens zweimal habe ich ein problem
in einem eigenen video
[Musik]
dann sprechen dann würde ich mal sagen
wenn wir zwei stehen max auf diesem
planeten die anderen beiden sind
trotzdem verlinkt und jetzt treten die
strafe und dann werde ich gefoltert weil
das sie in meinen zuschauer anständige
leute die sich übrigens bei guten morgen
internet abonniert die bafin super tolle
132 m zeigt das video für die chance auf
dieses klebeband das nächste mal wieder
8 1 1 0 1
[Gelächter]